-You know our first guest
tonight from his work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
where he serves as one
of the head writers
as well as co-anchor
of Weekend Update.
Season 48 of SNL premieres
Saturday, October 1st
on NBC and Peacock
with host Miles Teller
and musical guest
Kendrick Lamar.
Please welcome back
to the show
our very good friend
Colin Jost, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
I mean...
-Ah!
-Very nice to see you.
-Hi. Thank you.
That's very nice.
-And look, we're the real --
I mean, no offense to Tom --
We're the real Blue Man Group.
I mean, look at us.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right. It's great.
It's gonna be great
branding for us.
-I'm so happy to have you
back in the building.
You're gone --
you were gone all summer.
Did you have a nice summer?
Was it laid-back?
-I know.
I feel like we get to --
We have to like book appearances
to get to hang out together.
-We're very old friends
and we only see each other
on talk show appearances.
-I know, I know.
It's wonderful.
Yeah, I had a great summer.
Very...
We had a lot of family time.
We got to relax.
Like, I actually took some time
off to be with our baby, too.
-How old is --
how old is Cosmo now?
He -- He turned one.
He's somewhere over one. Um...
[ Laughter ]
I don't -- I don't c--
Like, you know, I don't ever
need to know beyond that.
Yeah, like when people are like,
"Oh, it's 15 months."
I'm like, that doesn't mean
anything to me.
Does not change --
Just like,
tell me when he's one.
Because then, before that,
he's zero, you know?
Then, and then I don't really
need to know till he's like --
till he's like five.
-Five? Okay.
I feel like one --
-So, you want to know one.
-Five...
And then I guess 25?
[ Laughter ]
Like, in case I need him
to, like, you know,
rent a car to take me somewhere.
-Oh, that's helpful.
-Yeah.
-So, basically, one to five,
that's one chunk for you,
and then you don't care again
until they can help you
rent a car.
-Yeah.
Yeah, like you're --
you have three kids,
so they're...
to me, they're like one...
-I have one -- Yeah.
So, I have one --
-They're zero...
-I have two ones and a five.
-Yeah, two ones and a five.
-Yeah.
-So, you'll tell me when
the other ones are five, right?
-Yeah, exactly.
-We're fine.
-I mean, you don't mind
if I call you right away?
-I mean...alright.
-Do you...
So, again, I consider you
kind of a laid-back guy,
but being a parent,
totally different.
Like, all of a sudden,
I feel you experience fear
in a way you never had before.
Do you have any fears
about being a parent?
-Lots of fears about
being a parent, yes.
I mean, the hard --
I think when you have a decent
imagination, it's worse.
because you can --
you don't have rational fears.
You have creative fears.
-Yeah.
-You know, like we actually
are not doing anything
to prevent the rational
problems that could happen.
Like, we're not -- we've done
no baby-proofing.
Every electrical outlet
is wide open.
And a lot of them
are the old ones,
like where they have,
like, you know,
baby-finger-sized holes.
-Yeah.
-And like, if you look in,
you see a little spark
that could,
like, catch a baby's gaze,
you know?
-Yeah.
-And we have, like, every table
has, like, glass objects --
every coffee table.
One has just like a ceramic dish
with small glass balls in it.
-You brought a photo of this.
So, first of all, like...
Even if you don't have a baby,
this is a [bleep] thing to have.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ] I mean, I --
-What is this?
-I mean, I...
This is kind of shocking --
I wasn't the one who bought it.
But I don't...
No offense to
the wonderful artist,
but this is for baby choking.
This is just...
There's no other...
-No, what baby -- first of all,
like, even if you're like. "Oh,
don't worry, we'll zip it up,"
like, any baby is gonna be like,
"I'm gonna unzip that!"
-And the great thing about this,
it doesn't zip up.
It's fake.
It's a fake ceramic zipper.
And I honestly think that
when our baby goes
and picks them up,
it's almost like if you see
someone dressed in a suit
in a bad neighborhood.
Where, like, "We should rob him,
but it seems like a trap."
It's too obvious.
It's got to be...
I think he looks at it,
but he's like,
"This is too obvious
a choking hazard. I can't."
-Yeah, right.
-"I'm not gonna fall for this."
-Yeah, it looks like --
like a sandwich underneath a box
that has, like, a stick.
-A stick, where you're like,
"There's something else."
-I should note that I didn't
realize this was ceramic.
I have more appreciation
for this now...
-Really?
-...then when I first said.
I mean, I bet if you told me
what it cost,
I might go back to [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
But I am impressed
with the actual craftsmanship.
-Yeah, yeah, no, it's --
the craftsmanship's great.
No, the artist is gonna
love the plug now.
[ Laughter ]
Well, so, we don't have...
So, we don't really do the --
but I have a lot.
My fear, like my number one fear
for what could happen to him --
eagles.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause bald eagles --
I don't know
if you know this --
-Unh-unh.
-Bald eagles are back.
-They are?
-In a big way.
And everyone's like,
"Oh, yay, they're back!"
-Yeah.
-Till you got a baby.
You know, it's the same way
people are like,
"Oh, the shark population's
come back!"
Till you look,
like every other day,
a guy in Long Island's
getting torn to pieces.
You know what I mean?
Not every other day, but...
But I am -- I mean, people are
like, "Oh, it's great" --
-I will buy that people
are excited
that bald eagles are back.
I've not heard a single person
be like, "Hooray, sharks!"
[ Laughter ]
-My grandmother
did tell me, like,
"Did you hear sharks -- there's
now sharks in the ocean?"
I was like, "Now?"
[ Laughter ]
But they...
No, but it is great
that the shark population
has quadrupled
and moved closer to shore.
That's really great.
I think everyone loves that.
-That's great.
-Eagles, to me, they're around.
-Uh-huh.
-And they're...
I mean, I haven't done
the research on this,
but I believe they're
the largest birds of prey
in America.
I would maybe even say
in the Americas.
I mean...
-Yeah. I'm gonna just --
I'm gonna just put money
that you're wrong.
-Yeah.
-But you keep going.
-Well, I mean, America --
Costa Rica,
obviously, there's --
there's islands off the coast
where there's pterodactyls.
I mean, that doesn't --
I'm not --
I'm not counting --
I'm not counting Isla --
-Anywhere...Nothing, like...
Non-theme-park birds.
-Birds. Yeah.
Then I think
that they're the largest.
-Yeah.
-And you know, there's more now,
so there's competition for food.
You know,
Thanksgiving's coming up,
and so they're probably like,
"Oh, I could grab that baby,
feed these -- feed these
baby eagles for weeks!"
I don't know what their
Thanksgiving traditions are.
-Yeah.
-We do a turkey.
But bald eagles might do babies.
-Yeah.
-And maybe one of them's like,
"Oh, maybe this year
we'll just do ham."
But it's like,
"No, we gotta do a baby.
It's Thanksgiving!"
You know what I mean?
-Right. Thanksgiving.
-So I'm terr-- I'm like...
We go for walks and
I'm scanning the horizon.
-Sure.
You're just on eagle watch.
-I'm on eagle watch.
And then we go for a walk
and she's got Cosmo
in the stroller,
and Scarlett puts
a little hat on his head
that has mouse ears.
[ Laughter ]
On the hat!
And I'm like,
"You're dressing our baby
like food!"
-Yeah.
-He's full of these glass balls.
[ Laughter ]
It's -- It's eagle entrapment.
And of course, by the way,
bald eagle --
they're bald, right?
Who are they gonna go after?
-Oh, right, right, right.
-If they're angry at anyone...
It's one of the only things
I've got going for me.
-Really good head of hair.
-These eagles are looking at me
going...
-"Should take that guy's baby."
-Yeah, that baby.
-You should have that artist
make a ceramic Cosmo.
-And try to feed it...?
-A decoy.
-Try to choke an eagle with it?
-Yeah!
Like, an eagle comes down
thinking
it's like a nice, soft baby,
and they're just like --
Bam!
-Doink!
-[ Laughing ] Doink!
He's gonna doink right off it.
-Hey...
-I'm great with sound effects.
They never let me do
my own sound effects.
-They never do.
It's such a bummer.
Hey, you and...
I want to check in on the...
You and Pete Davidson bought
an old Staten Island ferry.
-Yes. That's correct.
And you know I'm a professional
'cause I'm wearing
the life jacket on shore.
-You just can tell.
[ Laughter ]
This is...
You know how, like, sometimes
your friends do something
and you're like,
"Aw, why didn't they ask me?"
That is not how I feel about it.
[ Laughter ]
But do give me an update
on the ferry that you bought
with Pete Davidson.
-Oh, my God.
Financially, it's going great.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it is...
We are -- we are printing money.
It's -- It is our own money.
It's ferry bucks.
But we are printing it,
desperately hoping that a dock
will take it for payment.
-So, you don't have a dock yet?
-It's basically docked.
I mean, it's not gonna
just drift into the Manhattan
or anything.
It'll be fine.
-That's great.
-It's tied down.
-Is it exciting to buy a ferry
right as the sharks come back?
[ Laughter ]
We bought...
This is why idiots should not
be allowed to do things.
-Yeah.
-Pete and I bought this boat,
and then, like,
there's so many immediate
decisions you have to make,
and one of them is like,
well, you have to create
a financial entity
to deal with this boat.
And so we're on a call,
and I'm just like,
"Alright, well,
how about Titanic 2?"
[ Laughter ]
You know? And so, everyone
on the call is like,
"Oh, that's great,
let's do that!"
So that goes into a contract.
Right?
And so now suddenly
we're looking for insurance,
which we have to buy 'cause
it's a giant deathtrap boat.
So you have to get insurance.
And then every
insurance company's like,
"It's called Titanic 2?"
[ Laughter ]
And they're like --
same like as you,
they're like, "Is it docked?"
All these questions!
You're like...
-That's one question!
That's the first question
anyone's...
I like that you're like,
"Stop grilling me!"
They're like,
"Where does it live?"
-It's fine!
You have to also give it
its own independence.
-The boat?
-[ Laughing ] Just...
Next question!
[ Laughter ]
-Now you're in the building,
you're back.
-Yeah, yeah, we're back.
-You know, for the whole year.
You'll have to come back soon.
We want an update on everything.
And it's just always
the best to see, buddy.
I love you so very much.
-Aww.
-You guys, that's Colin Jost.
[ Cheers and applause ]
SNL returns live this week
for its season premiere
with host Miles Teller
and musical guest
Kendrick Lamar.
We'll be right back.